i gotta tell you rick it's pretty great
to be in this spaceship just the two of
us you know mentioning a grover
washington classic and not breaking out
into song immediately after
just the two of us
we can sin it if we try just the two of
us myself and i
i'm all alone relax that's what
windshields are for once you break
through earth's atmosphere shouldn't it
be called a vacuum shield i love doing
space sins because it's the surest way
to make sure i'm wrong about something
no matter how long i research it also in
this case vacuum shields are also for
keeping breathable atmosphere inside
your vehicle in fact i'd say that's
probably enough of the primary purpose
that this plot catalyst bug protection
is nothing more than a side benefit i
didn't know that there were bugs out in
space doubling down on the space sins
would a bug in space have those kind of
wings what do they even flap against
this space bug is a lie yeah i guess i'm
out of fluid that would immediately
freeze or float away or something
unrelated to what it would be intended
for space
for millennia our society has been free
of crime and war living in perfect peace
oh i know what this is interrupting
someone in the middle of their story or
explanation one night a year where you
all run around robbing and murdering
each other without consequence thinking
legal ramifications are the only things
that fall into the category of
consequences it's like the purge morty
that that movie the purge you're gonna
have to be more specific there are five
of them now
five of them and they aren't even done
making them yet you know sometimes it's
called the cleansing or the red time so
on the planet where it's called the red
time does it happen monthly instead of
annually because i think you may have
misunderstood hey justin i'm getting
ready to design a creature that'll only
be on the show for a few seconds what do
you think does it have two phallic
appendages on its face yep between them
does the mouth look vaguely vulvish you
know it a couple other boobs way ahead
of you hmm maybe a brown animated blob
by the butt so you can't tell if the
animal has a tail or if it's mid poop
dan you're a genius why don't you have
some candy bars as well aliens not only
speak perfect english but can also sell
earth items such as wiper fluid and
candy bars also the candy bars have
english written on them but all the
store signage is in an alien language
this planet is the worst how can you be
into this seriously after almost two
seasons of these shenanigans how is
morty surprised by anything at this
point why is reaction
what why ilching your words in space we
have something we call the
non-interference policy since
when leave you alone during a purge i
don't think so baby explaining you're
unable to stop purging as you stop
purging to explain about being unable to
stop purging what part of that gives me
anything to work with my choice is to
say nothing be sarcastic or bark yes
like a trained animal you forgot the
fourth option explain the situation meta
contextually in order to launch a b plot
no one will ever remember when thinking
of this episode you know like a typical
teenager i don't want to answer any more
purge questions that's funny i heard
ethan hawk say this exact sentence at a
boyhood press conference in 2014. can
you imagine being the doofus that asked
ethan hawk a second question about the
purge when he's there for a link later
movie this is for oblivious stevens from
how do idiots like this get into these
press events weekly you just now
remembered your nana exists rick calls
our thrisha out on her bullsh but still
follows her into the house which is
clearly a trap to get his gun and steal
his ship even if she sucks at it somehow
little mouse on the prairie here manages
to fly a space vehicle she's never
interacted with before one that we
already know has sentience and security
measures in place heads up rapists
assuming the criminal intent of purgers
purge them me no me should i rub my
liver hole on them
i only had one of those things i threw
i'm holding a box of tic tacs right now
saying this out loud wow within close
range of your adversaries
it's the space phone grandpa gave us
keeping the space phone your grandpa
gave you underneath the couch cushions
how was that helpful summer [ __ ]
summer there's a pile of silverware next
to you and you throw me the one thing
that can never kill anything he says
directly after killing something with it
morty if i can get to the top of that
lighthouse i can send the beacon and
your sister can launch our package
having a plan that involves a step of
having your sister launch your package
by the way life on other planets exists
don't let it distract you oh don't worry
no one here seems phased by your alien
existence unless it's needed for the
plot or a joke and i don't sense either
of those things present here fade in
exterior unnamed city day reading also
forcing someone to listen to you reading
your screenplay this is not her day
fade to black
title
three weeks earlier in media's res how
are these screwdrivers attached to the
wall velcro double-sided tape does that
affect the grip and why do you even need
them accessible on your wall toolboxes
have been sufficient for hundreds of
years rick hundreds of years do you have
any thoughts notes no i i just enjoyed
it that's my note you know morty would
be terrible at cinemasins i'm not a huge
fan personally of the whole three weeks
earlier teaser thing i feel like you
know we should start our stories where
they begin morty would be excellent at
cinemasins you're a petty person and
you're insecure and you're taking it out
of me that's a good script not sure how
the writers of rick and morty hacked my
email but at least they got some benefit
from my feedback from the studios folder
whoa morty we're guests here and is this
lighthouse full of healing magic because
rick's gun wound seems to have healed
nicely he's walking around like he
hasn't been shot in the gut for at least
the last 10 minutes you like that you
want me to cut to three weeks earlier
when you were alive
this show is just the best cut to once
in earlier when you didn't have as many
sins i remember when we used to go to
the playground and i'd push you on the
swings oh you could push me higher than
all the other kids why was he pushing
other people's kids i guess this is what
rock bottom feels like jerry being part
of a b plot so uninteresting and
pointless that the story only spent a
total of two minutes and 16 seconds on
it in the entire episode yeah i can see
what you mean how did the beacon track
rick and morty to this spot they left
the homing device at the lighthouse okay
morty now you're just shooting corpses
necro side honestly i've had my fill
it's gratuitous at this point rick
admits to fall to the show before
doubling down and partaking even further
in that fault anyway i feel like we've
seen this so much it's probably
repetitive by this point no need to sin
it again i suppose coordinated blood
dancing
feels good to hit song top the charts i
think explaining your references you
picked the wrong man to push movie
troutman first blood 1982. i need food
who's got food for that guy i do but
this is for me this sociopolitical
commentates on for some time and while
i'm making food for everyone who takes
care of my kids not being able to cook
food and watch your kids at the same
time that's not a real job trying to
explain my job to anyone in my family
over 50 somehow makes its way into this
episode jerry get a job okay fine two
minutes and 44 seconds i'm just saying
if this entire b plot was built on the
taddy madison skill you'd only owe five
dollars and 47 cents
my mom died
celebrating i didn't know that there
were bugs out in space i mean bugs i
hate bugs
boy you want to give me one good reason
why you would steal a snickers bar the
nougat why don't you have some candy
bars as well shut up i like candy also
if you tell your mom about this i'll
purge you are you threatening me my
bunghole will not wait i see [ __ ] like
that for breakfast morty but if you
don't do it i say it's because you're
afraid of your own primal instincts you
eat pieces of [ __ ] for breakfast no
what you doing watching some tv playing
on your phone it does other things
embarrassing no what's [ __ ]
embarrassing is having you as my father
a spoon morty a spoon i'm sorry why a
spoon cousin
why not because it's dull you twit it'll
hurt more
you thought this was gonna be a street
fight god damn right it is